from Komo News Bud Light sales continue
to drop down
21.4 percent following trans activist
partnership the latest data released
Monday by bump Williams Consulting shows
Bud Light sales for the third week in
April we're down 21.4 compared to the
same time last year the week before
sales were down 17 it just keeps getting
worse check this out competitors gain
ground core his lives up 20 Miller Light
sales are up 21 that means it means for
every one Bud Light someone does not buy
they buy one course and wow one Miller
yeah that's a lot that's a lot of extra
beer drinking they're like I'm gonna buy
one of each for every Bud Light you try
to summon by two of the other ones
it's crazy that they're not buying good
beer instead but it's better than
nothing I don't care what they buy as
long as it's not Bud Light amen the
Human Rights Campaign civil rights
activist group for lgbtq plus Community
penned a letter to Bud Light
demanding they're demanding that they
defend them they say when uh they were
super drunk on Bud Light right like this
is an outrage
she's a beautiful woman so there was a
bar in Indiana there's a bar in Indiana
that issued a statement saying if you've
got a problem with this then you can
leave dude you're in Indiana and then
they came back a week later they were
like we didn't mean it please please
come back what we meant was you can
leave a review on Yelp and come back on
in friends you can leave a big tip
because you ain't doing that stuff
anymore man I'm done I love this story
because uh
we're winning Bud Light is so desperate
not to apologize they're going to spend
millions in marketing they're hiring
ex-gop aids to assist them having secret
meetings but they're going to have to
apologize because they are for the third
week in a row and that was last week
right their sales are down
21.4 imagine what it's going to look
like this week it's going to keep being
bad you know the only way out is a it's
an apology well you know my family
actually I'm sorry I'm sorry I don't
even know if an apology I don't think an
apology would work I remember when I got
canceled I was told to apologize and I
was like even if I did that it wouldn't
work no I gotta make an apology yeah
this is different the woke mob canceling
people was never in good faith when Bud
Light did this the first thing everyone
said was just say you're sorry and we
will move on and buy your beer and I
said look if they just came out and said
we're sorry for sponsoring Don Mulvaney
we we won't do it again we we apologize
for offending our audience I'd be like
okay okay okay I'll still not drink your
beer no no I said I said you don't drink
it myself and I said go and stock the
entire office wow for our guests if they
were willing to apologize for having
done this and they are not in fact my
view of it is they are they're the
opposite of apologizing hiring having
secret meetings hiring GOP aids to
consult for them paying millions in
marketing is them saying we will do
everything in our power to not apologize
to our own uh to our own customers that
is the biggest Fu well they don't care
about their customers they don't care
about that exactly that's why if at this
point they have done it I do not see in
any way why anybody would want to be
associated with them at this point after
three weeks they could they could have
just come out after that first week and
been like guys we did not mean to
sponsor this person we had no idea we
are sorry about sponsoring Domo of any
end of story okay what's that thing for
a second where it was like oh the the
corporate people didn't really know that
this was going on yeah but they never
said sorry no no to be fair have you
ever been in an argument with someone
and then you realize like halfway
through you're wrong and you're like how
do I be a reasonable person without
apologizing here clear it's clearly
incorrect I am 100 wrong
spend millions of dollars to get out of
that situation if you had it would you
not be like
I would just apologize oh you're so
virtuously no I'm not I just know when
I'm wrong and it happens a lot well
you're wrong right now here's
apologizing here's what you do you quit
drinking and then right then you like
take the steps yeah
you have to apologize to everybody
everything's easier once you quit
drinking maybe I thought I should go to
AAA yeah exactly that round we apologize
to all our customers for thinking that a
whole bunch of men really wanted to
drink
sponsored by this fella in a dress
Anheuser-Busch and leading in the AAA
meetings how many lives have they saved
by stopping all these men from drinking
those are the kids are gonna write
letters thank you letters
people are are buying they're buying
twice as much
oh
apologizes taking
they're having I'm not drinking Bud
Light parties put them up to it I bet
these other companies were like you know
what would be really cool
chorus corsia has a meeting with the
anheuser-buschia he's always like we got
a dog playing chess and he's like you
guys think you're the biggest dogs in
the park but I got news for you our next
play is gonna blow you out of the water
and they're like really what do you do
well I shouldn't tell you
but we're sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney and
then Anheuser Busch guy gets up he's
like I have to go to the bathroom real
quick he runs he's like get
it and then however much they're paying
you I'll double it none of that 70 cents
on the dollar thing I know you're
actually I'll pay you a full dollar then
the Coors Light guy gets up and walks
away and laughs and Bud Lights now
so uh all of this all of this that
they're doing take a look at this story
this is interesting Bud Light owners
hired xgop staffers as Capitol Hill
lobbyists the same day they released the
partnership with Dylan Mulvaney they
they are doing everything in their power
to avoid actually just speaking to their
own customers I didn't say apologize
speaking to yeah they don't want to do
that they don't want to say anything
directly to these angry individuals to
the point where they've put two people
on leave they're spending millions in
marketing they're hiring these people
they made a commercial referencing 911
right that's so that's really desperate
did you see what Dylan Mulvaney did
Dylan Mulvaney's last most recent Tick
Tock oh I always keep up right I
actually do always keep up because it's
fun doing the only reason I have Tick
Tock has notifications turned on I have
push notifications they go to my phone
look at you but Dylan Mulvaney uh his
last tick tock instead of you know how
he does like 365 days with girlhood yeah
he skipped a bunch it was uh day 906
9601 of Being Human and I was like there
you go just be that just be human and
then you're basically fine but the video
that was put up by Mulvaney was saying
like you know people are saying anything
in the Press about me that's not my
truth and it's just like not my truth it
is the most that that is that is exactly
the problem yes it is what they're
saying was the truth but not yours
exactly like what are you God you get to
invent truth yourselves this objective
cult worldview these people have they
determine it's self-worship that's
literally so if anyone who says my truth
is engaged in self-worship there's
nothing is your truth
and the truth and the life yeah yeah the
logos these people Christ is truth he's
literally he is truth even outside of
that religious perspective it is obvious
that woke people worship themselves yes
the universe revolves around them their
reality is reality that is the
post-modernist subjective morality James
Lindsay is jumping up and down screaming
yes Tim yes Tim yes Tim right now well
what else is self-care
self-care is like preparation of the the
sacred vessel yeah amen well and the
thing the irony right about self-care is
you're not actually caring about
yourself you're just indulging in
selfish Pleasures that make your life
significantly worse in the long run Tim
you were you talked about how this is a
lotion and ice cream exactly not like
going to bed and getting up at a decent
time and going to your job and earning
and yeah I saw the first for the first
time I saw someone do a cover of a tick
tock bit you know the Dylan Mulvaney uh
bit that he did where he had the tampon
and stuff I saw another different tick
tocker oh no we didn't really do the
same bit it wasn't like a yeah
that like that guy Sykes I don't know
the name yeah so I'm telling you this
guy was one of the guy this guy pledged
to a bunch of sororities at I think
Alabama oh I think it was Alabama we
wrote about him a little bit today but
he pledged a bunch of sororities he
didn't get into any of them he got very
mad he posted all these prom pictures he
has his hair really short but it's got
like highlights he's clearly in a
feminate gay man which like okay go
ahead but uh here he is trying to get
into all these sororities and then he
started ripping off the Dylan Mulvaney
stuff because it was doing well for
Mulvaney and he must have been like oh I
I could definitely get in on this so I
watched some of his videos and yeah he
goes into the stores he makes fun of
tampons and it's like look none of us
like tampons either okay like nobody's
into it it's not something we're all
alive
you know you don't want to like bleed
all over that I like what they do though
I like the the but it's like performance
is the effect of tampons is useful but
we don't need to go into the store and
be like ogling all these cotton products
they do these uh these Instagram ads
where it's like people have periods and
it shows women with in their underwear
with stains and stuff
have you seen those the activist post
fortunately no there's been a bunch of
leftists
Runners do that they've posted images on
Instagram of them laying in bed in their
underwear with stains and my my view of
that is like no different than if a dude
had like crap on his ass I'm free
dude it's like why should
Society constrain my biological
functions and but hold on imagine if
people were this animated about toilet
paper and they were making out of
Charmin Bears they're excited they're
super pumped about toilet paper but
they're not against it though that's the
point they're not like toilet paper this
toilet paper is oppressive to Bear kind
why must I cleanse clean fuzzy bears
exactly
I don't like any toilet paper
commercials I don't like any tampon
commercials I hate they should be like
all the menstruation commercials like
just it's always a woman in nature
yeah
but in the commercials she's super happy
she's like out in nature on like a robot
and it starts sinking and she's like oh
no
I hate all that so much and you know
what like just you donate commercials
for these things get some wool yes you
do because your brand needs to be the
one that people know
when people think crappy butts they
think Sherman look people go to the
store they walk through the aisle and
they grab the one that's soft do you
know I don't know about what women do I
don't want to talk about it do you know
what you know what that you know how
there's been all this shoplifting at
like the Dwayne reads and the Walgreens
and everything like that so I keep being
afraid that when I go into a drugstore
it's all going to be locked up and I'm
gonna have to walk up to some teenager
at the front and be like um can you
unlock the Tampa they'll have like weird
color hair and be wearing a mask any
piece of that you know like just uh
she's got to be assertive you gotta be
like hey Doc I gotta wipe my butt open
the open the cabinet give me some of
that TP that's right what are you gonna
do hey everybody boops give me the Wet
Ones let's go Wet Ones
Tampax was sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney
which is weird and I I was I was wrong
did you ever see that South Park Dylan
with Kenny yes Dylan came out and said
after the backlash that the whole bit
was actually to help women because even
leftist women and regular women were
offended by what Doane was doing
marketing tampons yeah and so what that
that video is like I was just trying to
be helpful and then women got even
angrier because a bunch of ones started
posting like having a male come to you
in a bathroom explaining tampons no no
like
a woman is in the bathroom and a male
walks up to you and says would you like
a tampon and their goodness and that's
terrified and that's where's the holy
water and that's why the backlash just
got worse yeah now my Hope from all of
this is that companies just stop
sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney
he's got everything already he's got a
KitchenAid blender he's got Kate Spade
everything right don't like oil running
for president got the Republican
nomination and Dylan represents
algorithmic manipulation to no one and
but Bud Light is learning what that
means it means when the algorithm says
something is popular it is not just
because people are looking at it does
that mean people like it and what is on
the Internet is here's here's what's
actually happening there are Fringe
groups in this country that normally
don't have the the relationship to each
other to organize in large numbers that
means if one person in every major city
in the U.S believe moved in you know
space lizards
there's no great space lizard
organization but the internet allows
them to congregate digitally this then
results in someone getting a hundred
thousand views on their space lizard
video but these people don't organize in
the real world now you've got companies
being like who's that guy who's got a
hundred thousand followers oh space
lizard guy he's great let's sponsor that
whereas people normally are like that's
not okay Dill Mulvaney gets views
because the algorithm props it up Bud
Light says sponsor it regular people say
what the are you doing this is not okay
now they're reeling from it I hope other
brands take notice and stop sponsoring
algorithmic manipulation thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time